part of the problem is
when you look at it it says show that
there's a point
x y where x
is not zero so
make the transition this x and this y
they're constants okay they're constants
it can be hit by firing at two different
angles theta one and theta two
so what's the situation you've got
something like this right and they're
picturing some point in the air
for instance because it could be
anywhere it doesn't have to be on the
ground
okay and what you should be able to do
is hit it from
two different ways right you should be
able to hit it high up and you should be
able to hit it from
low down as well so you've got to feel
one and
a figure two okay now actually drawing
that like that doesn't
really establish anything that's going
to help you solve the question
necessarily like
this isn't going to get you any marks
but you've got to have a clear sense in
your mind of what am i trying to work
out here
okay because that's the difference
between okay i read this answer now
and it makes sense to me versus i can
think of this answer myself because i
understand what's going on
okay right so
remember i was trying to alert you to
the fact that this is a quadratic and
it's a quadratic in tangent theta so
let's try and make that a little more
obvious because it's sort of in a
mishmash weird form it's in a form to
make this equation a path
obvious but it's not in a form that we
can work with as a quadratic in tangent
theta
okay so let's put it into general form
and
tan theta is kind of like our x squared
if you like because we're used to seeing
this kind of thing
right yes
so instead i want to put it into this
form
okay where these are my that's what
makes my quadrant okay
so to do that i'm going to have to
expand out um so i can get this tan
squared on its own
so i'm going to have this
minus one on four h now i should have
stopped
um these two here when i start working
with this point okay
they're now constants they're not
variables anymore so
i don't know if your if your capital
wise and your
capital x is very different okay but
let's make that transition because um
what you look at in part two doesn't
have any lowercase x's or y's in it
they're not they're not variables
at all so what have i got that's a
capital x
squared now i've got one of them and
then i've got another one
but this has the tan squared on it
okay now i'm going to skip a few lines
because i'm running out of space but
after you rearrange all of this
if i want to get it looking like this
here's what it's going to look like
you're going to get this y and this 104
h
x squared they're going to be together
because they're completely constant
terms
y is constant capital y is constant
capital x is constant
h is constant right so they're going to
be
that's going to be my c okay over here
on the end
so if i have let's see how do i write
this
i'm gonna have this guy on the front
and i'm gonna have this one
and then i'm gonna have what have i got
these both become positive
i think
that's all we can see okay this looks
like a disaster it looks like a mess but
all i'm trying to do
is put it in a form that's easier to
work with it's going to lead to my
inequality
okay all right now let me just put some
colors on it so you can see what's going
on
that that's a that
is b and that is c
is that okay not slowly at me if you can
see where i'm going okay
good now that i've got it in general
form
i can now move toward this inequality
that they've got okay
what does the inequality mean it says
show that the point
um x y can be hit by firing at two
different angles
okay now the angles are theta one and
the two
i've drawn them up here okay now what
that means is this equation here
has two solutions okay corresponding to
theta one
and theta two but don't forget this
isn't a quadratic
in theta is it there's no theta squared
in here
there's tan squared okay so one of my
solutions
will be um i'll do it like this
one of my solutions will be tan theta
one and the other one will be tan
theta two okay does that make sense
just keep that in your head for part
three okay now if i know that there are
two solutions
and the two solutions are different okay
if i'm gonna have
two different or a better way to say is
two distinct solutions
for a quadratic what does that tell me
about the quadratic
it's the discriminant right okay now do
you see why you're like people you have
to make the leap
from projectile motion to quadratics
okay and that's a hard lick to make yeah
because if you want two solutions
well yeah roots is a tricky word to use
because it's kind of like it implies you
know collision with the axis
but um they are kind of roots
discriminants will always work and what
you've got is in the form of a quadratic
any kind of quadratic okay this is a
weird quadratic i admit
but it's still a quadratic with two
solutions
yeah that's right it's a little bit like
those circle questions do you remember
from like say year 10 kind of era and
they're like look you've got a um you've
got a circle
and there's a tangent or something like
that okay now again
because the equation of a circle is has
squares in it right and the equation for
that straight line is going to be linear
when you solve them together
you get a quadratic okay now if there's
a tangent what do you know
one solution that means the discriminant
will be equal to
zero right so that's how you can use
discriminate in questions where it
doesn't seem like it's about
like quadratic theory what's that about
all these random numbers but here it's a
physical situation
okay so i'm going to say for two
distinct solutions
the discriminant should be greater than
zero okay and this is sort of your
bridge to get to the inequality which
we're going to land on in the question
okay so what is the discriminant it's b
squared oh sorry where's the bracket
minus four a what's that
that's a and this is c
that's greater than zero okay now i know
that looks like a terrible mess okay but
they give you some clues in the question
because remember they actually tell you
what you're required to prove
you want to get to here um
x squared is less than
this okay um we've done the hard part of
the question
the hard part of the question was
putting it in this form and then landing
on
this inequality the rest of it is just
algebra it's just algebra
okay now quick question do you want me
to show you the algebra
or are you fine do you think you could
get there
raise your hand you want me to show you
the algebra
okay i'm going to give you my page you
can have a look at it um
it really is not that hard um when you
think about what you've got here and the
fact that there's an extra 4h
right essentially what you're doing is
multiplying through by 4h
twice okay doing it once gets rid of
this one and then doing it again gets
rid of
this one and that's why your extra 4h
lands on
here okay so that's why there's a 4h h
minus y
okay but it's yeah it's you just got to
be tidy with the algebra and make sure i
mean it's you kind of have this
advantage of knowing what the condition
will be at the end
so if you screw up just backtrack be
slow don't do lots of steps at once
but that's where you land now